ils sont fiers de montrer leur carte
d'accès
il nous montre leur carte depuis 5 ans
une quinzaine de jeunes vivant avec une
déficience intellectuelle plus sévère
sont en stage deux jours par semaine
dans les bureaux de l'auto-québec et au
Casino de Montréal notre objectif c'est
de leur confier des tâches qui vont être
capables d'accomplir puis qui vont leur
permettre de travailler leur motricité
leur autonomie de se réaliser aussi puis
des fois c'est les employés qui ont le
flash de dire j'ai pensé à ça je vais
aller voir les petits rois pour leur
demander si c'est possible de faire
cette tâche là vos affiches sont partout
dans les dépanneurs la Fondation des
petits rois c'est le combat de vagna
pour son fils Henri-Louis et pour des
dizaines d'autres jeunes vivant avec une
déficience intellectuelle
modéré à sévère des familles pour
lesquelles les services s'arrêtent
abruptement toutes les forces qu'on a
mis depuis que son tout petit jusqu'à 21
ans à estimé à le garder
à l'aerte et garder toujours
occupé leur cerveau
21 ans plus rien à la maison c'est là où
j'ai commencé à penser ben il faut créer
quelque chose il faut créer vraiment
un projet novateur un projet où on va
réitérer des listes d'attentes cette
clientèle qui ont une défiance plus
prononcée qui sont tout à fait capables
de livrer la marchandise madame Aguiar a
convaincu Loto-Québec d'accueillir les
jeunes et de leur donner ce qu'il faut
pour réussir des tâches simples et
répétitives comme retirer les anneaux
des cartes privilèges des clients du
casino qui arrivent à l'automne c'est
que les petits rois vont être avec nous
à temps plein
tes ateliers adaptés il y en a
maintenant huit dans différents
entreprises dont un qui vient de
commencer ses activités à urgence santé
connard une éducatrice spécialisée du
Sud qui vient accompagner nos jeunes
pour pouvoir les aider à accomplir cette
tâches donc elle crée des camps vases
pour que nos jeunes soient capables de
compter par exemple ainsi les
paramédiques trouvent le nombre requis
de pansements dans leur trousse pour les
moments où chaque minute compte pour
nous c'est hyper important déjà la
remise en service mais le travail est
déjà fait ça leur permet d'accélérer à
d'autres choses c'est vraiment un
travail d'équipe parce que tout le monde
s'entraîne probablement ce qu'on va voir
Richard fosse est enseignant en classe
spécialisée il a préparé ses élèves au
marché du travail en développant leur
concentration et leur dextérité
au niveau des attitudes des
comportements
des règles sociales quand ils vont être
dans leur milieu alors j'ai travaillé
tout ça avec eux surtout au début pour
de bien les préparer maintenant ils sont
sur l'horaire d'aller ils sont vraiment
formidables
ils sont les premiers finissants du
programme des petits rois une grosse
étape de terminer puis là on le sent
adulte là il va travailler au casino à
temps plein on est vraiment content et
soulagé vous allez bien on va danser ce
soir puis on va fêter ça
a été un gros gros poids de moins sur
nos épaules à tout le monde Hugo est en
est fier aussi
il y a une belle équipe qui l'entourait
génial madame vanilla je la remercierai
jamais
depuis 5 ans de nouveaux employeurs se
sont ajoutés
ivanya agar en trouvera d'autres pour
qu'il y a un bal chaque année ici à
Louise despaty Radio-Canada Montréal